Neville Longbottom after the battle of
Hogwarts Neville didn't waste any time
in pursuing a career as an aura and
gifted Aura he was however it later
become clear that being an aura wasn't
his true passion and when he was offered
a position at Hogwarts by now had
mistress manev mcgonagal he accepted you
see Neville was also particularly
passionate about one subject while at
school hology and it just so happened
that his new role would have him working
under hology department head Pomona
Sprout Neville would eventually go on to
marry former classmate Hannah Abott a
Hufflepuff student and former member of
dumo army because Hannah worked as a
land lady for the Leaky cauldron it was
only natural that Neville and Hannah
would live upstairs but they lived for
many years after some time Hannah
eventually applied for the job of matron
at
Hogwarts Ron Weasley
the